it's a human gift empathy it's a
superpower
if you can do it you can see so much
more
[Music]
hi we're the cast of knots and crosses
and today we're going to be doing a
round table to give you guys an inside
look into the show and how it relates to
the world that we live in today
my name is masali baduzza and i play
selfie hadley
hi my name is jack rowan i play callum
mcgregor
what's good i'm bonnie bully and i play
jasmine hadley hello my name is josh
dillon and i play jude mcgregor
hi i'm jonathan ajayi and i play lekon
barco
hi i'm patterson joseph i play kamal
hagley and later i'll play this very
tiny guitar for you all
right so i just wanted to ask everybody
what has been the uh sort of reaction
around you guys with your people because
there are some of us who are in south
africa
i know where everybody else is but a few
londoners it's been interesting for me
to to see the reaction and the reaction
from everybody i found is
is a a curious
discomfort you know
um everybody is going
this is hard to watch for many different
reasons
also depending on where you're at in
your life and where you're at with that
kind of conversation and how real
you interact how like how authentically
you you interact
with the elements of it but the reaction
has been love the performances love the
world
um the it looks insane it's just like a
visual
feast but all those things are kind of
like the candy that
pulls you into the uncomfortable
conversations you're almost not ready to
have with yourself
i really care about what the rest of the
world thinks about this but
i i've just been watching closely what
south africans are saying
and um and people are people love it
they love it in south africa so but
interestingly
josh's character and jonathan's
character
both like and um jude
that they're almost like our opposite
antagonist so i'd be interested to see
how those extreme characters were
perceived amongst your friends
either of you um
people did not like my character
jonathan everyone that i spoke to loved
your performance they were like
your performance was yeah
yeah but the performance the performance
is different to the characters
everybody says oh my god what an actor
that's amazing that actor
and then i went what did they say about
the council
it was all kind of messed up on both
sides but some people were saying
oh man it's nice to see us getting
revenge just like on screen
right wow my friends they they're very
honest people
uh and then some other people were
saying but
actually if you look at you were still
playing the stereotype of an angry black
man
and i think both things hold true well i
you know i mean and
obviously as actors we try not to judge
the characters you know that's
it's really important not to judge who
we're playing let's find the
every dimension of the humanity you know
so i never saw him as a villain never
saw him as like a revenge character i
never saw him as like
some kind of superhero for our real
world but just a product service
of his environment do you know what i
mean which
which was liberating to play you know i
think because this show was so
touchy and it's literally it's pressing
every button of every like
association that you have with race
people
characters were individually triggering
people's perceptions and the lenses in
which they look at people and
their experiences and everything you
know so i couldn't expect
anyone based on what they looked like to
say something that
i thought they would say also uh
i just think about your character john
and how
like it's not just two it's not
two-dimensional
there are so many shade like throughout
the series you know you go from
seeing like the kind of the how horrible
privilege and entitlement can be you
know in a person but then you also see
like a real vulnerability and stuff and
i think that's what i mean i know your
uh your character wasn't in the books
but like
i think it's the same same applies to a
lot of a lot of the characters in the
original books like mallory has done
that really well that it's not
it's not actually black and white you
know you see people who are
three-dimensional and have kind of many
facets their characters which is really
interesting because one minute you're
thinking like
oh they're a stereotype and one and
they're that kind of person i know where
they're coming from and then
it could be you know five minutes later
you're like hang on a minute
so it's constantly hopefully asking
people to sort of
challenging perception yeah their
perceptions and and sort of change their
perspective which is really cool
and how did your friends react to jew to
jude's character
mike i don't know really you'd have to
ask them people were quite sweet
and people quite surprised um
you know i'm not really like that in
real life i mean
so it's quite that we know you're sweet
we know you're a sweetheart
we do that i'm such a good boy
he really gives you so much love on set
because you know his character is
antagonistic towards everybody even his
own family
you know the poor actor who's having to
play that slightly treat people a bit
like the characters they play
so we gave you a lot it was easy because
we're a lovable guy but yeah that's
tricky
i feel like um now that we're actually
have
having this conversation in this way i
feel like
uh um jude and
uh lechon are actually mirrors of each
other
yeah and then it brings home that idea
that it doesn't matter
what race you are or what your
background is
these you find these people in life you
find these people in families
you find these people reacting this way
to situations which brings us back to
that place of like
yes sometimes it's just not about race
this is who people are
people are just people it's so true it's
like in both characters you see
the reality that whether you're poor or
rich whether you're black or white
no matter what pain manifests you know
in
pain manifests you know and what there's
a saying i saw
during lockdown on twitter someone
tweeted something really great which is
that
hurt um hurt people cut people
bleed on other people do you know what i
mean
and that's what jude is doing that's
what lacan is doing that's what
callum we find callum doing to sephie
and sephie doing vice versa and every
single character in the show is
bleeding on someone who doesn't really
deserve to have that in their face
you know and i i guess it's just it's
the complexity and the vulnerability of
giving your heart to other people you
know
regardless of what they look like
we're social beings so we socialize and
that trust is misplaced
that trust is respected you know and
those are the things that inform how you
interact in the world
you know like one of my favorite moments
is um
jack when you come back after dropping
out of mercy point you say i'm not a
failure
he said i'm not a failure i'm not a
failure i'm not a failure and and
sephie's like no
you're you're not a failure not a
failure you know but they're saying it
from two different places two different
experiences
two different lives up to that moment
but beautifully
they can both navigate this
new decision and this new path in life
together you know
the other thing to say is about um it's
about cliche isn't it it's like
what are you expecting when you see a
program like this and i think it busts a
lot of cliches i mean jack's character
massani's character
you're both sort of busting within the
show the cliche of who you're meant to
be
as those people and i think people
watching it are expecting something
that they didn't quite get it was more
nuanced than they expected
you weren't a good guy all the time
masali wasn't a wise and
open and an understanding girl all the
time and that's a
that was a big clash i asked jack first
did that seem
could you see the dimensions of the
character instantly or is that something
you found
through the work well definitely i'd say
you know
there's only so much you can know before
you actually get on the set
but it was only really when i actually
got to cape town
and got in front of masali and in front
of all you guys
where actually truly becomes alive and
you put the costumes on
you get your hair done a certain way and
that's when you look in the mirror and
you feel totally different
and constantly callum and sephie
off the back of what jonathan just said
about the whole sort of
that scene i'm not a failure they're
both learning about
each other's worlds you know like
just because you know you know
masali's character constantly even from
the first scene we have together
when the khan comes and interrupts us
interrupts a lovely moment
you know with the whole plaster scene
you know
sephie may never have seen a plaster
that closely
on a naught's skin and i think
immediately she goes
whoa like that looks really odd on you
like i've never really thought about it
and i think
that's what the audience hopefully get
from that too i know i did when i read
it in the book
i went whoa i've never thought this
deeply about plasters
and it brings me back to when i was in
school though
um and how you know if you graze your
leg or anything
you just get a plaster but that plaster
tends to
favor a more caucasian skin tone so even
in something so
small that can make someone feel
alienated
you know how powerful that a tiny thing
like that
can make a person feel other you know
like not included in the normal because
in britain
i have been in my own country othered
in that subtle way is
magnified by all the other things that
happen
disproportionate incarceration of black
men
and women the disproportionate uh lack
of educational
um facilities level and opportunities
and certainly jobs and housing and all
the way down the line
and it starts with you're not this
therefore you must work to be this other
and you even
sitting in the makeup chair would have
been othered
but you'd be bothered where however you
look you're being othered into what is
acceptable if i follow on from that
point
it's the time when i did um military
training
in cape town before we started filming
um
you know there were there was there was
times where i was sort of on my own
and i and i mean jonathan was there so
he could back me on this
the sergeant major we had it was almost
like it was for real he was addressing
us as cadet mcgregor and all that
and he was giving jonathan the role of
leader
you know like you lead these naughts and
lead these crosses in marching
but what i found is i looked around and
i was the only
naught there you know or one of one of
four
and as the days went on there was times
when i was me and
jody who played a north we were the only
cast members there and dan told like
the other soldiers the other cadets he
was like no look at them strangely
like don't they're not allowed to sit
with you at lunch
you know don't don't look at them get
like if you look at them give them dirty
looks and
we were sort of even though it was
make-believe
you know i was there for maybe five days
and we're in the sun we're working out
you know i forgot about that make
believe a lot of the time i was thinking
on the spot i was present and
admittedly you know i'm a white guy from
london
surrounded by culture my whole life i've
never been put in a situation where i've
had to be the other
and i remember at the end of that
experience at the end of the military
training i wrote in my notebook
and i just simply wrote don't forget
this feeling
lovely and it was one of the things that
was
as i said earlier in this in this chat i
said
um it was a big part of where that is
that where i became
callum it helped with the journey that's
so powerful that's so amazing
i mean that's some deep stuff right i
mean that's as actors we don't often get
to go that deep where it really touches
something
real that's going to resonate in our
lives afterwards so that's very powerful
to hear and hopefully
that's what happens to some members of
the audience watching it but masali now
you've got a character who is
the privileged girl the privileged girl
who hasn't had to even
look at what poverty means hasn't
even had to look at what lack of
meritocracy means how did that go with
you
um that's actually one of the things
that really attracted me to the script
was
playing a black girl who lived in a
world that was
designed for her um i thought that that
was that was
gonna be really powerful to play and it
was um
and you know sethi's definitely not
perfect she's definitely you know
still growing and learning you know
within herself and
in the first episode i mean when she
called you know
calum and you know the people around him
blankets like
she would never have thought that that
is the person that she was but it's this
internalized you know racism that she's
just been consuming her whole life
that that is you know that that led to
that moment
and um and i also will say um
it's like kind of off topic but i think
notes and crosses is so important
in this like time especially right now
because
the other week um in south africa uh one
of
the stores like um released an advert
where they had like a white woman with
her you know straight long hair
as normal hair and they had a black
woman with her curly hair as dry and
damaged hair
and this is in south africa this is in a
country that
you know 80 percent african and black so
it is it's just it's so important for
people to watch the show
to recognize their privilege and
recognize that
the system that we live in is is not
made for black people for people of
color
you know and and i just hope that it
urges people to
to make a difference in their own
communities you know to
to buy from black businesses to support
black people because
the system is not going to do that
interestingly enough
i thought what what um when i was
looking just trying to examine
where jasmine stands in relation to
how she contributes to the oppression of
the notes around her
and whether she cares about it whether
she wants to be part of making the
system better
and it i i consistently came back to the
point where i was like
jasmine is so selfish is so caught up in
her own needs
she she's for me those people who are
like if
i'm not racist i've got white friends
was a person
right that's jazz it's like levels of
engagement isn't it
is that how what on what part of the
spectrum of engaging with this societal
problem are you engaging
you know yeah like exactly jasmine's
like well
i didn't do nothing so i'm gonna live
this life this is just a genuine
question i'm thinking out loud a little
bit
but write down is
is the word racism or racist specific
enough to match the complexity of
each individual microaggression
wow wow that's a powerful yes just this
is a genuine random question that came
to mind
i mean in my mind racism is
a kind of ideology
and most people wouldn't confess to an
ideology
even if what we as black people would
experience
what they're doing or what they're
allowing
to be racist they wouldn't acknowledge
themselves as being ideologically
racist which is why you have that that
sort of wall
that comes up with even white
liberals who you might consider your
friends and are on site and have never
given you any
indication of any racism the wall of
defense that comes up
is based on the fact that they haven't
yes as you say done anything and their
ideology
is actually rather eclectic and open
so you can have you know there was a
famous uh actor who pronounced on
a chat show uh political talk show that
he
to be nameless but you know look him up
um
that there was no racism in england now
i can see from his point of view that
they might not be
they have never had literally the light
shone
on racism around them so therefore it
can't really exist
they have some black friends and their
their black friends may be like them a
little
you know affluent or successful
and so they don't really see it for the
majority of people
and it is that sort of innocence that
frustrates
uh black people so much because it's not
that you can point at them and go you
are a racist
we all you could say is you're blind i
call it
snow blindness it's like everything
seems fine
until something pops up like black lives
matters
and says can you examine really deeply
examine
how you perceive these people
and that is when you get the clash of
very like
minded liberals suddenly thinking i have
to take a side here and what you're
asking me is not just simply to be
not racist but anti-racist
to be active about acknowledging
racism around you and that's a very big
leap for a major i would say the
majority of white people because they're
not ideologically
racist but they are by default by
allowing
and by their snow blindness and not
seeing
that meritocracy which is i suppose what
this actor was trying to say
it's only meritocracy from from a
a perspective and it's it is
literally it is if you are white you
can't see it
in certain spaces and if you're black
you see it all the time that there is a
lack of meritocracy and it is literally
relative
to your position and how you see it and
to ask somebody to shift their position
and look
from another's perspective it's a human
gift empathy
it's a superpower if you can do it you
can see so much more
i think it's particularly effective in
the lives of white people this book kind
of is
really sort of shocks people and stuns
people into
as we've been talking about shifting
your perspective it forces you to think
about very simple things um that mean an
awful lot
and i suppose it's particularly
effective because we're not often asked
to do that
as white people i remember you i
remember you it's like in the midst
of a filming telling me this has been
difficult for me
because i've had to walk a walk that
i've never
walked in my life i've had to go into
the mind of somebody who hates
an entire ethnicity because of the color
of their skin now of course there's the
other political thing you're being
oppressed by this
uh ethnicity but you said it was a very
difficult thing for you to walk that
line
can you talk about that a little bit
okay so i i mean
absolutely but what's been so
interesting since the show has come out
and uh particularly with george floyd
i mean it's staggering to think that the
start of our show
notes and crosses essentially you know
the parallel is just so scary
and it's so shocking and it's the real
one and you know you could
so so as an actor i might have found it
difficult you're right pattern i might
have said that to you
but i really struggled sort of after it
came out for and i'm still struggling
now to sort of
um to not feel i don't know if you feel
the same jack
but to not feel slightly like you've
fallen
like so short of connecting to
to that feeling what that must feel like
um
that i was just very kind of raring to
to i i'm
keen to do for season two to do more to
kind of learn and absorb more and to try
and connect on a deeper level
you took it you took all the words out
of me i mean it's it's one there were
certain moments in the
filming for me where i could go yeah i
feel like i'm
learning a bit more you know but then as
josh said you know
as an overall i've only skimmed the
surface really
nuts and crosses is a
love story set in the backdrop of racial
turmoil
it's a story in which the wealth gap in
the class gap
are divided for us ultimately to
understand that the human experience
is similar and vast no matter where you
fall on that spectrum
they pick up two characters a young
naught male and a young cross female
and it just sort of follows them on a
journey
of sort of discovery and learning about
each other and
falling in love and how in this world
a naught on a cross they can't mix it's
not respected it's not
it's not allowed naughts and crosses
mallory blackman's norths and crosses is
better than shakespeare's romeo and
juliet
hell yeah yes said it
i've worked quite a bit on shakespeare
and what you have to understand is
shakespeare was the playwright like any
other playwright except he had a genius
that
many other playwrights don't have but
what he doesn't do
necessarily is write a detailed world he
doesn't he doesn't need to
that's all contained in the poetry what
mallory does
is tell us why the capulets and the
montagues are in dispute
we get it in the in the play but nobody
really cares or remembers
why whereas this takes the
macrocosm of the world that romeo and
juliet are fighting to be together in
and it makes it center stage and that's
what's more powerful and i would say
more adult about this drama
is it says the forces arrayed against
this
amazing love are so powerful
they are monolithic it is almost
impossible at the beginning for us to
see them getting together
and if we have that in in shakespeare's
romeo and juliet however powerful it is
and it is very powerful
we would get it to the nth degree
because
the battle that they have to fight the
battle in the hearts of each person
watching it
and the question i said this before is
does love conquer all is it powerful
enough
to destroy a world that is totally
set against dividing these people take
the situation
of the proverbial situation of
star-crossed lovers
and and imagine that the stars that
cross
are race and class and northern crosses
invites you to
ask the question could we as human
beings
and cross those stars and evolve to a
place where
love can be allowed to thrive i've said
this before but
being on the set of knots and crosses
was like
therapy almost because seeing
black culture um celebrated and
held to such a high regard that it
already is but seeing that
on television which is something that
you know you don't see often it was
powerful you know i stepped on set
when i was you know around the hadleys
and around crosses feeling like
royalty and black people royalty african
culture
is beautiful and and the show celebrates
that and that's what i love
so much about the show and i hope that
black people watching the show can see
the excellence in themselves represented
by the crosses
i graduated from the same school that uh
patterson joseph went to and for me
those three years and now and walking
around those hallways and seeing that
black and white picture of him in his
graduation show
he was a role model an idol someone that
i would walk past and see the likes of
him and david or your lowell so then to
be in notes and crosses
being a young black privileged man being
able to stand and speak from my chest
and then seeing him on set
it's just chef's kiss i can't even the
words it's difficult to find the words
do you know what i mean but hopefully
this
is this is not an answer to
the expression of black voices but it's
the beginning of a very very long
expression of black voices i
i wanted i want to say that i i
never imagined that in my in my lifetime
as a black actress i could walk on to
set
not having imagined by
packing into a suitcase a variety of
wigs and a variety of ideas around
how i can fit into the beauty standard
for the first time
how i came was enough it was
an honor to be telling this story
which hopefully speaks to so many people
and it's not often that you get to do a
job that's so
um challenging for as an actor but also
you know it's going to be challenging
for an audience so it just felt like a
real honor to be part of
an amazing group of people telling this
story
likewise it was an honour for me as well
it's nice to see that when the brief was
sent out
from carson directors the brief wasn't
just oh we want to see
it was specific as in we need a young
black male
as in so i'm not going to waste
anybody's time this is who we want
and hopefully in the future more
projects can start from the ground up
where it's written for black actors not
oh we'll just cast somebody because we
need to appear diverse
you know and i think nelson crosses is a
show
it's based on a book it was always we
always needed
a female black lead we hope you enjoyed
hearing more about our show
please don't forget to stream notes and
crosses for free
on peacock
you